Musik
Können wir den Fall lösen? Wir sind ein Rätsel auf der Spur. Hier ist die Podcast-Ufo-Dedektei mit Florentin Will. Hallo. Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Neben mir sitzt natürlich Stefan die Nase Tietze, kein Fall, den er nicht schon auf Meilen riecht. Ich habe eine große Nase, ja. Es ist aber auch... Nein, ich meinte dann mit deinem Spürsinn, einfach deinen genialen kombinatorischen Spürsinn. Ich stehe jetzt nicht, warum du es immer wieder sagen musst. Ja, aber sag doch, der hat eine gute Auffassungsgabe oder so.
Aber immer diese Nase, ja, ich habe halt ein grosses Riechorgan.
Rieche ich besser dadurch eigentlich, dass ich ein grosses, habe ich mehr Rezeptoren?
Das weiß ich nicht, haben wir vor zwei Folgen mit dem Hund.
Aber finde ich gut, dass du auch direkt als Detektiv in diese, ich bin gebrochen, ich habe innere Konflikte, ich arbeite gerade, was durchgehst, was ja gängig ist. Ich habe das Gefühl, es ist eine gängige Detektiv-Trope, ne? Ja, ich glaube, wenn es mal einen Krimi gäbe von einem Detektiv, der einfach sagt, ich habe ein gutes Privatleben. Ich bin mit mir im Reinen. Ich verstehe meine Frau, meine Frau hat auch manchmal Verständnis dafür, dass mich für einen Fall einfach mal länger im Büro bleiben muss. Ich habe eine süße Tochter und alles ist gut. Das Gegenteil davon. Ich sehe meine Tochter häufig, meine Frau ist komplett damit im Reinen, dass ich teilweise einen Monat lang weg bin. Ich gehe in Therapie, da kann ich das gut verarbeiten, dass ich manchmal Leichen sehe. Ich hatte kein Alkoholproblem, habe ich noch nie. Ich kann auch gut Nein sagen. Bei Drogen kann ich auch gut Nein sagen. Und wenn man jetzt mal so viel will mit dem Fall, dann kann ich auch mal gute Niederlegen. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht so, dass ich obsessiv den Fall lösen muss. Ich gebe das gerne auch an die Landeskriminalamt ab oder sowas, wenn der Fall irgendwie ein bisschen über den Kopf wächst, habe ich überhaupt keine Probleme damit. Ich habe keinen Ex-Partner, mein Ex-Partner ist nicht gestorben, lebt nach wie vor, wir verstehen uns beide gut, wir haben ein gutes Verhältnis miteinander, lösen das beide sehr gemeinschaftlich und so. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich muss auch nicht immer raus irgendwie, ich kann auch mal im Büro arbeiten. Was mir besonders gefällt, ist, dass mich meine Fälle auch nicht in soziale Brennpunkte führen, wo ich in irgendwelche schwierigen moralischen, gesellschaftlichen Konflikte reingerate, sondern ich kann das gut einfach abstellen. Und um 10 Uhr bin ich zu Hause. Also ich habe eine gute Work-Life-Balance, von daher ich liebe meinen Job. Ich liebe meinen Job und ehrlich gesagt, es passiert auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Und ich war auch noch nie so wenig Haltüberkopf in einem Fall gefangen. So einen Mord habe ich jetzt auch noch nicht gehabt. So ein Fall ist ja eh Teamwork. Also die Forensik macht da total viel und irgendwie auch Datenanalyse. Also ich selber mache da gar nicht so viel, nur ein Teil. Man stellt sich das immer so spannend vor, aber eigentlich ist es auch sehr viel Büroarbeit, einfach mal ein bisschen am PC sitzen. Klar, und auch Leute anrufen und nachfragen und so, Zeiten checken und so, es ist ganz locker. Die neue Show! Jetzt auf TV Now! Der langweiligste Krimi aller Zeiten! Ich schaue tatsächlich, wie der Krimi ist momentan. Ich bin ja ein großer Fan von The Sinner, eine Serie, die sich mittlerweile in der vierten Staffel komplett verloren hat, mit dem einfach von den tiefsten Traumata gequälten Detektiv, den es überhaupt nur gibt, der jede Staffel in Rente geht, aber dann trotzdem zufällig auf einen Fall stösst, der ihn nochmal aufwühlt und er einfach, egal was passiert, wenn jemand irgendwie eine Tomate schneidet, oh Trauma, ich habe eine Tomate, irgendeine Leiche hatte meine Tomate im Mund, dann irgendwie geht es irgendwie in den Zoo und sehe eine Giraffe, oh irgendeine Leiche hat, und egal was dieser arme Mensch macht überall Traum hat er, wo man einfach seit zwei Staffeln schreit, geh in Therapie, verdammt nochmal! Geh nach Hause, geh in Therapie! Lasse, such dir ein Hobby! Aber nein, egal wo er ist, eine Leiche fällt vom Dach, genau ihm vor die Beine, ich kann das nicht vergessen, Albträume, Halluzinationen. Diese Serie ist mittlerweile echt eine Parodie von sich selber geworden, aber ich schaue sie gerne an, es ist so ein bisschen mein Guilty Pleasure. Ich habe neulich, jetzt nachdem die neue Bond rausgekommen ist, nochmal den ersten Bond mit Daniel Craig geschaut. Oh, sogar mit Sword. Auch da hatte er schon keine Lust mehr zu arbeiten. Heißt, in jedem einzelnen Daniel Craig, James Bond, war er am Anfang dieser gescheltene Charakter, der keine Lust mehr hatte zu arbeiten und nochmal zur Arbeit getortiert wurde. Ich finde das ohnehin merkwürdige Prämisse. Du gehst in den neuen Bond-Film und weißt, der Hauptdarsteller hat eigentlich keinen Bock mehr drauf. Ich meine, wie gehst du denn da ran? Ich meine, Schauspieler sind so glorifiziert, Leidenschaft brennen für ihren Job, magern sich ab, irgendwie trainieren wochenlang für ihren perfekten Körper. Tagelang hätte sie fast gesagt. Minutenlang. Und dann siehst du da einen, wo ich mir auch einfach denke, der könnte doch wirklich auch einfach sagen, er hat auch am Set keinen Bock und ja, hier, Peng, Peng, Hilfe, ich bin im Zug, ich hänge draußen dran und so. Und man würde da irgendjemand sagen und sagen, Daniel, du musst schon ein bisschen, du musst ein bisschen schon Gas geben. Ach ja,, komm. Das passt auch zu seinem Gesicht, erinnert dieses mich beeindruckt gar nichts mehr. Und es passt eigentlich auch zu Bond. Bond hat eigentlich auch immer so schon eh schon alles gesehen. Bin Bond, häng am Zug. Bin am Zug und Giftpfeile schießen mir den Nacken, oh mein Gott. Oh, aber noch nie gehabt. Oh, noch nie gehabt. So, sind wir bald da. Der hat eh schon alles gemacht. Von daher, fiel es gar nicht so schlecht, aber ich habe den neuen Bond nicht gesehen und werde ihn vielleicht auch niemals sehen, weil ich plane für meine Rente, ich will in meiner, wenn ich Rente habe, will ich irgendwie schön nochmal alle Filme, die ich auf meiner dicken Festplatte gesammelt habe, ich habe so eine richtig dicke Festplatte, die ist wirklich wie so eine Brotdose dick. So ein Buddenbruchs. Genau, wie so ein Buddenbruchs. Das war auch eine geile Einheit eigentlich. Wie viele Buddenbrucks ist die groß? Ein Buddenbruck. Mensch, aber ich bin bis jetzt reich. Das habe ich das mal gesehen, da bist du vier Buddenbrucks gewachsen. Ich bin ein bisschen gewachsen, ja, ja, vier Buddenbrucks beziehungsweise fünf Voidsex, also die nächste ist schlecht. Elle stattdessen. Kann man auch sagen, Elle, ja. Oder Zoll. Was ist ein Zoll? Ich habe so eine richtig dicke Festplatte, wo ich alles drauflade, was ich nicht gesehen habe. Stranger Things, nicht gesehen. Schaue ich mir an, wenn ich schön mit 68 irgendwo in meinem Baumhaus sitze, schaue ich mir die alle an in meinem Beamer oder meinen Augen. Kontaktlinsen, die per Bluetooth dann halt mit der Festplatte verbunden sind. Ganz ehrlich, wenn Bluetooth noch eine Rolle spielt. Ich hasse auch Bluetooth. Vor allem, ey, wirklich, ich habe es letztens mal versucht, gleichzeitig am Desktop zu sein, Bluetooth verbunden mit keinen Kopfhörern und nebenbei mein Handy mit Bluetooth verbunden mit der Box. Also zwei Bluetooth-Achsen in einem Raum und Bluetooth hat gesagt, ich bin zu schwach, ich kann es nicht, ich schaffe es nicht, ich bin verwirrt, links, rechts, links, rechts. Hat sich wie so ein Käfer auf den Rücken gelegt und gesagt, kill me. Ja, ich verstehe das genau. Ich verstehe auch nicht, was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Bluetooth, erst mal so rein physikalisch, zwischen Bluetooth und so WLAN-Wählen. Man merkt gerade, so eine Grüppchenbildung, weil die einen Anbieter auch so bei Homespeakern setzen komplett auf WLAN, andere setzen noch komplett auf Bluetooth. Und da merkt man so, da teilt es sich gerade so ein, zwei. Und ich würde echt mal wissen, was ist der technische Unterschied, was ist schneller, was ist sicherer, was ist beständiger. Ich glaube nämlich, das Bluetooth ist gar nicht so, es ist halt wie so ein starker, wie so ein Güterzug, schlägt man es vor. So ein bisschen langsam und behäbig, aber halt relativ stark. Wenn es erst mal hält, dann stark. Die Waggons sind so sehr eng beieinander, wohingegen WLAN eher so ein Hochgeschwindigkeitszug ist. Aber den kann man auch, so ein Windstoß würde den auch umkippen. Ich habe immer das Erlebnis, ich habe meine Bluetooth-Kopfhörer und dann gehe ich vom Rechner weg in die Küche und dann merkt man so wirklich genau dieses, oh, jetzt bricht es langsam ab, ich höre nur noch jedes zweite Wort, wenn ich einen Schritt nach links gehe, höre ich nur noch jedes dritte Wort und wenn ich noch einen Schritt weg gehe, dann ist es komplett abgebrochen. Aber ich liebe das, das ist so knallhart, diese Grenze ist wie so gezogen im Lineal, wohingegen WLAN immer so ist, jetzt zieht eine Wolke auf, geht nicht mehr.
Ich weiß nicht, aber du hast völlig recht,
aber ich weiß nicht, welche Technologie danach kommen könnte, aber das stelle ich mir vor,
ich meine, irgendwann werden wir alle Cyberkontaktlinsen
tragen, wo gesamte Computer drin sind,
mit Festplatten, Internet verbunden
und alles ist in der Cloud und dann sehen wir überall
Sachen und können einfach
mit einem Fingerschnipp unser gesamtes
Blickfeld ändern und das gesamte Blickfeld ist Fargo und wir schauen einfach Fargo, egal wo wir hingucken. Oder Argo. Oder Argo, je nachdem. Primär die beiden. Oder Go, je nachdem. Fargo, Argo oder die Go-Doku. Wie die Zukunft sich noch entwickelt, man weiss ja nicht, was lauert, gilt ja der nächsten Ecke der Zeit. Ja, finde ich spannend. Ich war vor einiger Zeit
im Europapark in Rust
mit der Familie
und da, ich bin ein großer Fan
des Films Valerian,
der Luc Besson filmt. Wirklich? Ja, ich mag den ganz gern.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum,
jetzt nicht, weil der Film so toll, aber ich mag diese Welt einfach gern
und hatte da Spaß. Und da gibt es
diese tolle Szene auf diesem Markt,
auf diesem Interdimensional Markt, wo man sich so Helme aufsetzt und dann kann man diesen Interdimensional Markt betreten, das ist ja eigentlich nur eine große Wüstenfläche, so eingemauert und dann, wenn man diesen Helm aufsetzt, dann betritt man diese Welt. Und im Europapark gibt es eine Achterbahn, die ist eine Indo-Achterbahn, die komplett VR ist, nämlich spielt die auf diesem Markt. Und dann geht man quasi rein, kommt dann in so einen Raum und kriegt dann so einen Helm gehändigt, eben den gleichen Helm, den die auch da im Film bekommen. Setzt den auf und darunter ist dann eine VR-Brille. Und man betritt dann diese Interdimensional-Welt. Und seit dem Moment in diesem Warterraum am Anfang siehst du nichts mehr. Du siehst niemanden mehr. Also außer halt deine, die computergenerierten Aliens neben dir. Das heißt, deine Begleitung ist plötzlich ein Alienwesen oder sowas. Und jetzt gab es einen kleinen Funfact davor, dass das Prequel zu der Story war, ich bin zunächst rein und die ganze Familie, wir haben wie gesagt so ein Europapark-Wochenende gemacht, haben sich dann, weil dafür muss man nochmal Karten extra kaufen, Karten gekauft für diese Achterbahn, haben uns angestellt, alle sind schon reingekommen und in dem Moment werde ich rausgezogen aus der Schlange von diesem Mitarbeiter vom Europapark, hat gefragt, wie groß bist denn du? Und ich so, ja so 1,97 und er hat gesagt, na komm mal mit. Und dann hat er so hervorgeholt so ein Messding, wie man das kennt, ob man für Kinder ja, ob die gross genug sind für Achterbahnen. Nur das hat eine Maximalgrösse und die war bei 1,95. Und da habe ich mich drunter gestellt und gesagt, nee, du kannst nicht rein, du bist zu gross. Das war einfach die rotierenden Kreissägen über dem Kopf schweben und die einfach abziehen. Ja, meine Vorstellung war, dass man, wie man das ja kennt, dass Achterbahnen sich ja überkreuzen und so und du teilweise unter so einer Schiene herfährst, dass ich einfach dann so einen Balken im Gesicht habe. Das war meine Vorstellung. Aber hast du dann gesagt, ja, okay, oder hast du gesagt, hey, ich riskiere es. Sag mir nicht, welche Achterbahn ich fahren kann und welche nicht. Ich war eher zweiteres, ich habe gesagt, nee, komm, aber ich kann ja schon mitfahren, oder? Und er so, nein, ihr geht es maximal größeröße. Ich habe gesagt, ja, ich stehe da einen Punkt, sie können mitfahren, aber sind halt nach der Fahrt zwei Zentimeter kürzer. Das muss ihnen halt klar sein. Ja, jedenfalls Ende vom Lied war, ich bin nicht mitgefahren, nur um dann quasi am Ende des Tages mich noch mal anzustellen, in der Hoffnung, dass jemand ein anderer Mensch da ist, der vielleicht entweder irgendwie ein Gefühl für grosse Menschen hat oder aber, der seinen Job so schlecht macht, dass er mich einfach reingehen lässt. Und drittens habe ich mich ein bisschen kleiner gemacht. Wie hast du das gemacht? Buckel. So ein bisschen so ein Buckel. Wie Buckel. Ich bin eher so ein bisschen gekrümmt gegangen. Verstehst du? Und du hast die Schuhe ausgezogen. Ich bin oft angelehnt. Buckel. undnt. Wenn du so ein bisschen auch breiter in die Beine gehst, bist du ja auch kleiner. Genau. Aber das kann entlarvend sein, weil es so spinnenartig so langgliedrig wirkt. Könnte einen entlarven. Ich habe mich immer an Wänden angelehnt, so ein bisschen leger. Einmal so lässig an der Wand. Wie groß sind sie? Kommt auf den Winkel auf den Winkel an. Und dann bist du reingekommen, oder wie? Ja, beim Zettel bin ich einfach reingekommen. Du hast ja einfach reingecheatet. Du bist ein Lawbreaker. Du bist ein Outlaw. I see a lot of Lawbreakers out there. Niemand kann dich fassen. I'm a little Lawbreaker. Wow. Und dann habe ich mich da reingestellt.
Verhaftet, du bist hier mit verhaftet.
Naja, was ich aber verdrängt habe quasi, war, dass man ja dann, wenn man erstmal diese Information hat, dass man zu gross ist für diese Fahrt, auch dann keinen Spaß mehr hat an der Fahrt. Ja, totes Angst, ja. So, weil, und ich wusste auch nicht genau, wie es aussieht, jedenfalls hast du die ganze Zeit diesen Helm auf und das Problem ist schon, du gehst ja quasi, du bist ja in diesem Warteraum, kriegst dann diesen Helm auf, siehst schon alle Characters, was ganz geil gemacht ist, weil der Einweiser ist der gleiche, der Typ, den man dann sieht, ist nämlich genau der Typ, der auch im Film diese Ansprache hält, wie dieser Markt funktioniert, so groß wie zum Turban. Sehr lustig. Niemand hat diesen Film gesehen, also die Referenzen feiern ein bisschen flach. Alles klar. Was verstanden werden kann, ist, dass ironischerweise mein Charakter, also alle haben dann zu mir geguckt und ich war sehr klein. Ich war so ein 20 cm großer Wurm, auf den man so herabgeguckt hat, der dann so zum Wagen gekrochen ist. Irgendwann geht dann diese Tür auf und vorher wurde erklärt, wie du dann einsteigst. Du siehst wirklich nur diesen weirden Markt, hast kein Gefühl mehr für den Raum, was echt ist, was nicht. Du siehst nur, da geht so eine magische Tür auf und du siehst, manche Aliens folgen so, feilen auf dem Boden und gehen dann lang. Und dann gehst du wirklich raus aus diesem Raum, komplett blind, nur mit dieser computergenerierten Welt und steigst dann da in ein Raumschiff ein. A.k.a. die Achterbahn. Aber stösst man da nicht in andere Leute rein oder irgendwas? Die siehst du ja, die sind ja diese Alien-Characters vor dir. Ach so, okay. Und nicht weil dieser Wurm, der so langgekrochen ist. Und ja, dann setzt du dich quasi in ein Raumschiff rein, also in eine Achterbahn, die siehst du aber nicht. Das heißt, du setzt dich plötzlich in eine Achterbahn rein, die du vorher nie gesehen hast. Und dann steigst du da ein und machst dann diesen Bügel zu. Und da war, glaube ich, der Grund, warum ich, warum 1,95 die Maximalgrösse ist, weil du den Bügel über deine Knie bekommen musst. Diese Überkopfbügel, kein Problem. Diese Bügel, die von unten kommen, bleiben an den Knien hängen. Es geht gar nicht um die Körpergrösse, sondern um die Beinlänge. Ja, aber da muss man viel differenzieren. Also da muss eher meine Beine messen. Bist du eher beinlastig oder eher oberkörperlastig? Gute Frage, ich glaube, Männer sind eher oberkörperlastig, von daher, ich hätte kein Problem. Ich habe auch schon lange Beine, das weiß ich nicht genau. So, und dann saß ich in dieser Bahn und ja, jetzt dann ist die Bahn losgefahren und war alles eingebunden, richtig geil in diesem VR-Ding. Super schick schon auch und war ein cooles Erlebnis. Aber halt, ich habe keinen Spaß gehabt, weil ich die ganze Zeit dachte, ich sehe ja nichts. Also selbst wenn ich jetzt so eine Balken auf mich zurasen sehe, bei einer normalen Achterbahn, bei jeder anderen Achterbahn könnte ich mich ducken. Ja, zumindest. Ich finde den Versuch starten, mich zu ducken. Bei dieser Achterbahn nicht, ich sehe nämlich nichts. Und ich habe auch noch über mir so einen Helm auf, auf dem auch noch eine Antenne ist. Das heißt, es ist ein bisschen zwei Meter achtzig gross. Ich bin so zusammengerechnet zwei Meter achtzig gross, hänge vielleicht in einer Achterbahn, vielleicht auch nicht, habe den Bügel vielleicht zugemacht, habe ich nicht gesehen, weiß ich nicht und habe primär Angst gehabt. Ich habe die ganze Zeit einfach mich ganz klein gemacht und es war mega seltsam. Du weißt auch nicht, wer neben dir sitzt, weil du siehst dann diese Alien. Neben mir satt die ganze Zeit so ein Alien, was so stur nach vorne geguckt hat, so ein großes Ding. Es war wirklich sehr, sehr merkwürdig, diese Fahrt. Aber ich finde, es ist genial, dass es auch einen Markt gibt für Leute, die zwar mit der Familie in den Freizeitpark gehen, aber keinen Bock haben, ihre Familie zu sehen. Und dass es stattdessen einfach ersetzt wird durch irgendwelche Schleim-Aliens, wo man die einfach gar nicht sehen muss.
Ich habe gedacht, woher weiß ich denn jetzt, ob ich eine Achterbahn gefahren bin und nicht einmal so ein weirden Simulator, weil der ein bisschen geruckelt hat.
Vielleicht ist es genau das die Idee.
Weil die haben die ganze Zeit, die haben betont häufig gesagt, bitte nehmen Sie während der Fahrt nicht die VR-Brillen ab.
Und auf gar keinen Fall nehmen Sie die VR-Brillen ab. Und ich war geneigt zu fragen, warum nicht?
Ich glaube, da kommen einfach drei Praktikanten und schütteln dich oder schütteln deinen Stuhl einfach und du fährst überhaupt gar nicht, passiert gar nichts. Naja, dann war er nicht so schön. Und niemand kennt ja auch den Film, wie du schon sagst, niemand versteht das. Aber das finde ich ja eine spannende Welt, dass ja so Freizeitparks diese Franchises kaufen müssen von bestimmten Sachen. Und natürlich, klar, alle haben Bock auf Disney oder Harry Potter oder Star Wars. Aber es gibt halt auch kleinere Freizeitparks, die dann halt solche kleinen Franchises sich holen müssen und ihr einfach wenig Geld haben. Es waren vor allem nur Franzosen in diesem Ride, weil ich glaube, das ist nämlich eine französische Franchise. Zum einen ist Lupin-Saint ein Franzose, der den Film gemacht hat. Zum anderen ist Valyrian eine französische Comicbuch-Reihe. Ja. Und ich glaube, Franzosen lieben das Franchise.
Und da waren nur Franzosen mit in dem Ding.
Also, na ja.
Das ist schon interessant.
Ich würde auch mal interessieren, was ist das billigste Franchise?
Also wenn du jetzt wirklich sagst, wir machen in unserem Garten eine Achterbahn und wir haben Bock auf Franchise, kriegen wir Snoopy, kriegen wir Tim und Struppi?
Ich glaube, ich kann das beantworten, diese Frage, weil der Europapark ist ja so ein bisschen, versucht er die ganze Zeit auf Disney zu machen. Europapark ist ein Off-Brand-Freizeitpark. Der Jahr Freizeitpark. Ich liebe die Jahr. Medion. Und die ganzen Achterbahnen, weil es ist ja gegründet von der Mack-Familie, ein Achterbahnhersteller, die haben erst dann quasi das Areal genutzt, um ihre Achterbahntests zu fahren und so und Testbauten zu machen. Ach, geil, Achterbahntestfahrer. Genau, dann haben die das quasi irgendwann zum Freizeitpark gemacht. Und sie wollen eigentlich ja nur Disney sein, ne? Ja. Also, weil das Maskottchen ist auch eine Maus. Ed. Die Maus Ed. Nicht Mickey, Ed. Und dann hast du ... Ist es kurz für Edward, oder? Weiß ich nicht. Und dann hast du ja auch den Pirates of the Caribbean
Freizeit Ride,
der da heißt dann
Piraten von Batavia oder so
und ist quasi genau das gleiche. Du hast auch
Cortez, also es ist genau das gleiche
wie für der Karibik. Batavia.
Dann hast du Space Mountain quasi auch
einfach nachgebaut und so. Du hast
einfach quasi alle Achterbeine, die es bei Disneyland
gibt, eins zu eins mehr
oder weniger leicht verändert,
so dass die Lizenzen schon hinhauen,
... nachgebaut und so. Du hast einfach quasi alle Achterbeine, die es bei Disneyland gibt, eins zu eins mehr oder weniger leicht verändert, so dass die Lizenzen schon hinhauen im Europapark. Und ein Franchise neben Valerian haben sie nämlich doch. Und das ist, glaube ich, die Antwort auf deine Frage, was ist das billigste zu bekommene Franchise? Die Antwort ist Arthur und die Minimois. Nochmal bitte fürs Protokoll. Arthur und die Minimäus. Minimäus. Arthur und die Minimäus waren Film. Was sind Mäus? Mäuse. Minimäus. Ich zeige sie dir. Und davon gibt es eine Achterbahn, was keinen Sinn ergibt, weil es gibt ja die Schweiz, Holland, Russland, Frankreich als Länder und dann das Arthur und die die Mini-Mois-Land. Das sind Mini-Mois, auch Luc Bisson, lustigerweise. What? Also die haben alle Rechte bekommen von den Luc Bisson-Filmen. M-O-Y-S, Mois. Also es hat nichts mit Maus zu tun. So Kinder-Franchise-Filmen, das sind so kleine Elfen oder so. Das habe ich noch nie gesehen, das sind so kleine Kobolde-Elfen mit Mäus. Aber habe ich ganz vergessen, ist ja auch ein Loupe-San-Film, heisst, die haben einfach seine Franchises bekommen. Ja, aber warum nicht das fünfte Element? Warum nicht den coolsten Loupe-San-Film? Das ist schon verrückt, oder? Also da gibt es ja bestimmt irgendeinen Marktplatz, wo man diese Franchises kaufen kann. Das klingt doch die Leon der Profi. Ja, das ist ja der Schießstand irgendwie, finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Finde ich interessant, also wirklich, da müssen wir mal rumfragen, was ist wirklich das Billigste, gerade das in Deutschland, kannst du irgendwie so den Bärenmarke-Bär oder so, kannst du den holen. Mantamant oder Werner oder irgendwie sowas dazu, ich glaube, das ist relativ teuer, da kannst du so Sachen machen, aber dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Ballermann oder so, irgendwie so Franchises, Bulli-Parade. Lambock. Ja, genau, sowas in der Richtung. Ich glaube, da kannst du, natürlich ist es nicht ganz so einfach, deine Achterbahn rumzubauen. Aber sowas in der Ecke finde ich gar nicht. Da habe ich auch gedacht, ich würde sofort ja sagen, wenn mir jemand sagt, hast du Lust, eine Achterbahn zu schreiben, also so eine Geschichte. Ja, das ist ja schon cool. Würde ich sofort machen. Also wirklich, wirklich, würde ich sofort ja sagen. Sagt mir eine Summe, ich mache es dafür, ich mache es für hundertwesen. Willst du eher so die Action-Achterbahn oder so diese langweiligen, wo man so ganz langsam mit einem Schiff durch Wasser fährt und links und rechts passieren Sachen? Da kannst du dich, glaube ich, ein bisschen mehr selbst verwirklichen. Ja, da kannst du eine spannende Geschichte erzählen. Genau, das war auch ja quasi die Piraten in Batavia, war ja genau das, war ja quasi Flutter Karibik in Ride. Ich weiß nicht, wie das die Originalgeschichte war damals in dem Pirates of the Caribbean Ride, weil wir wissen ja alle, unser Lieblingsfranchise Pirates beruht ja auf der Achterbahn im Disney. Richtig, und diese Achterbahn beruht eigentlich auf einem Shake, einem Milchshake, der Piratenshake, der damals angeboten wurde, die dachten nicht, der kommt so gut an, lass uns da eine ganze Achterung brauchen. Genau, und der Shake beruht eigentlich auf einer Maserung in einem M&M, wo Leute gesagt haben, ist das Pirat? Nee, ach doch nicht. Und das quasi ist die Genese des Films. Und der beruht eigentlich auf einer Tapete, die einem von vielen Baumärkten angeboten wurde, die Piratentapete, die kommt so gut an einfach, Warum nicht weiter? Finde ich eigentlich schon eine gute Idee. Ja, also falls ihr da
draußen einen großen Freizeitpark
habt und ihr habt noch so einen weissen Fleck
auf der Karte, wo ihr sagt, da hätte
ich gerne noch die Stefan-Tietze
Experience, die hätte ich hier gerne
noch drin, wo du dann einfach auch
vielleicht der Franchisegeber selber bist,
einfach dann so du als das Tietze-Franchise,
du bist ja selber schon eine Marke, muss man ja auch mal sagen. Ja, eine ganz kleine. Die Leute kennen nicht, 1,97. Das ist schon ordentlich. Und dann stehst du und dann ist dein Körper vielleicht so die ganze Achterbahn oder so, man fährt wahnsinnig weit hoch und fällt dann runter oder irgendwie so was, da kannst du ja wirklich du dich austoben. Aber dass er mich reingelassen hat und dann war ich auch auf einer Achterbahn und da habe ich auch danach gelesen, auch bis 1,95 maximal.
Boah, ich habe Angst vor Achterbahnen, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, weil ich bin ja Detective-Connan-Fan und da im allerersten Band, ich glaube auch in der allerersten Folge sind sie ja auf dem Jahrmarkt, wo Shinichi geschrumpft wird. Ja, und da gibt es auch den Mordfall, dass einer in der Achterbahn getötet wird, nämlich indem so ein Drahtseil über die Achterbahn gespannt wird, sodass der einfach enthauptet wird. Wo ich mir denke, ja, erstens, wie viele Leute hat dieser Mangel alleine dazu gebracht, nie wieder in eine Achterbahn zu gehen und wie viele fucking Psychopathenmörder hat er dazu gebracht, genau das zu machen. Das konnte ich sehr einfach recherchieren, wie viele da bei der Enthauptung durch eine Achterbahn gestorben sind. Ja, weil das ist schon krass irgendwie. Ich meine, da kannst du schon echt viel Schaden anrichten. Und von daher kann ich gut verstehen, wenn man danach keinen Bock mehr auf Achterbahnen hatte, sondern eher dann in die Hüpfburg geht oder sowas. Achterbahnen sind auch merkwürdig. Ist ja, wie merkwürdig ist das? Also das ist so das ist so komisch. Das ist ein bisschen wie so ein Multidimensional TV bei Rick and Morty eigentlich. Das ist so andersweltlich, andersartig. Streicht mal kurz euer Wissen davon, wie Freizeitparks aussehen und sowas. Und nochmal von Null. Und versucht mal kurz euch hineinzuversetzen in so eine Alienrasse, die hierher kommt und sieht uns, wie seltsam sind Achterbahnen. Wie würden die das interpretieren? Ob das eher so eine Art Foltermaschinen sind oder so, wo die da drin hängen und rumschreien oder was passiert da? Dass man so Strassen baut, also quasi so Züge auf Schienen, die aber in so Geschwindigkeit, die waren ja nicht schnell, ich war 70 kmh oder so. Ja. Aber das sind natürlich schnell, weil es halt Freiluft ist und
so scharf kurven. Ich vergesse auch manchmal,
wie wild
Achterbahnen sind und sowas. Also ich war dann zum Beispiel
in München, da gibt es dann auf der Theresienwiese,
also wo normalerweise das Oktoberfest ist, aber da ist
auch vor dem Oktoberfest hier und da schon so Feste
und da bin ich einfach mal so mir nichts, dir nichts
mit so einem Kettenkarussell gefahren, das so
ganz hoch in die Luft geht.
Wo ich dachte, ich bin ein erwachsener Mensch, kein Problem, irgendwie kann ich damit fahren, ist ja nett. Und ich hatte solche Angst. Du hast ja, wenn du wirklich auch schon seit locker 15 Jahren nicht mehr in einem Kettenkarussell saßt und denkst so, ja Kinder haben da Angst und so, aber nein, Höhenangst ist eine wirklich tief im Menschen einprogrammierte Angst und auch so dieses Wissen so, ich komme hier nicht raus. Also ich kann nicht sagen, okay, passt runter, sondern nein, das ist halt so. Und wenn du da hoch bist und an diesen Ketten, an diesen dünnen Ketten bei Kettenkarussell, wo du denkst, ich meine, wissen die, dass ich auch einfach mir schon drei Packungen gebrannte Mandeln reingezogen habe? Haben die einen Blick auf mein Körpergewicht momentan? Wissen die, was da los ist? Nein, aber seine Körpergrösse ist ja das Ding. Ja, ja, ja, okay, gut, ich verstehe, dass du da erbost bist. Ja, aber er hat mich nicht einfach reingehen lassen, like ein Idiot, wann schreit ich da durch die Pforte und wird geköpft von... Ja, bis mal was passiert, bis du dann mal wieder zwei Zentimeter, ich meine, wie viel Körpergrösse könnte man verlieren, ohne dass man ernsthafte Probleme kriegt? Ja,, glaube ich. Naja, du hast ja schon Kopf und dann Kopfhaut und Schäde. Ja, gut, okay. Das ist aber keine Rasierklinge, die über deinen Kopf schnellt, sondern wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schippst du an einem Genickbruch, weil du bist ja nicht oben einfach abgesägt, wie wie bei den Simpsons. Da kommt einfach so ein Holzblock, wo du gegenfährst und dann ist dein Kopf weg. Ja, ja, aber wenn der hoch genug trifft, ist das auch nicht so schlimm, oder? Schürfwunde. Du hast doch ein bisschen Dotzraum, auch wenn du, du kannst doch deinen Kopf auch ein bisschen nach unten drücken. Mit Dotzraum meinst du Frisur? Ja, zum Beispiel. Zum Beispiel, die Frisur lenkt das alles ab. Aber ja, ist auf jeden Fall unangenehm, bitte seid vorsichtig. Und falls ihr da in der Achterbahn arbeitet, nehmt das nicht zu Lachs und lasst da auch die Leute nicht rein, egal wie groß sie sind. Auch wenn sie 90 Minuten lang anstanden, ist unangenehm, aber da müssen sie halt durch. Ich habe jetzt aber mit einer Gefahr... Was bist du eigentlich für ein Vorbild? Entschuldigung mal. Ja, ich weiß. Was bist du eigentlich für ein Vorbild? Die ganzen Hörerinnen und Hörer, die gerade zuhören, sagen, ach, man kann also Regeln brechen und es gibt keine Konsequenzen, auch wenn ich riesig bin, kann ich überall mit rein, setze alle Leute in Gefahr. Ich meine, der ganze Jahrmarkt könnte zumachen, wenn da einer enthauptet wird in der Achterbahn. Hast du daran eigentlich mal gedacht, an die Konsequenzen, warum es diese Regeln überhaupt gibt oder denkst du nur an dich? Naja, ich denke so wenig an mich, dass ich, obwohl ich größer bin als vorgeschrieben, reingehe. Und naja, ich glaube ja an Regeln, ich glaube auch, dass es sinnvoll ist. Und ich möchte auch eigentlich die Leute beim Europaparkat ins Gericht nehmen, dass sie da jetzt mich durchgehen lassen. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Das kann ich mir nicht anhören. Erst die Regeln brechen und dann sagen, ja, ich wollte ja nur mal zu deren Gunsten testen, ob man die Regeln brechen kann. Nee, nee, nee, so nicht, Stefan. So kommst du mir hier nicht aus der Schläge. Jeder muss selbst entscheiden. Ich würde dich da auch eher abraten. Aber ich meine, er kann so haben, weil guck mal,
du kannst ja in jeder Achterbahn auch Hände in die Höhe strecken.
Wie alle Achterbahnen sind dafür ausgelegt,
dass Leute die Hände nach oben strecken.
So groß bin ich ja auch nicht, dass wenn neben mir jemand sitzt,
der 1,80 oder 1,95 groß ist, wenn er die Arme hochstreckt,
der ist grösser als mein Kopf.
Die Arme sind länger als zwei Zentimeter insgesamt. Würde ich jetzt mal behaupten. Steine These. Deswegen bin ich sehr fest und überzeugt, das liegt an meiner Beinlänge. Und da muss jeder jetzt mal selber an sich heruntergucken und sagen, habe ich zu lange Beine, um den Bügel zu bekommen. Das ist ja auch meine Schuld. Ich habe für mich entschieden, nein, meine Beine sind kurz genug, als dass ich den Bügel zubekomme. Und hatte Recht. Hätte ich den Bügel nicht zubekommen, wäre ja spätestens da raus sortiert worden, was ich nicht, ich weiß nicht, wie das gelaufen wäre und was dann die Animation in meiner VR-Brille gesagt hätte. Das heißt, du würdest eher sagen, man geht nach Rosenlänge. Was haben sie für eine Rosenlänge, um dann zu sagen,
die haben eine zu lange Rose, ihre Beine sind zu lang,
sie dürfen nicht rein. Ja,
ich finde, ihr solltet keine Regeln brechen,
gerade wenn es um eure Sicherheit geht.
Ne? Having said that, jeder muss auf sich selber
achten und selber wissen, wie lange
seine Beine sind.
Und wenn ihr da arbeitet, möchte ich
euch nicht in die Pfanne hauen, die machen alle schon einen super Job, gucken halt nicht so mega genau hin. Und ehrlich gesagt, beim zweiten Mal, als ich reingegangen bin, stand dieses Mesting auch gar nicht mehr so sichtbar da oder diese Regel bis 1,95. Ich finde es auch gut, dass sie das erst holen müssen, warum steht das nicht immer da? Es stand beim zweiten Mal gar nicht mehr da und nirgendwo war sichtbar erkenntlich beim Gehen in die Achterbahn, dass es bis 1,95 ist. Und das war auch so unangenehm am Anfang. Natürlich die ganze Schlange, die warten ja da darauf, dass mal irgendwas passiert. Alle warten auf diese Attraktion, haben Langeweile. Und dann plötzlich wird ja so ein Lulatsch aus der Schlange gezogen und an diesen Pranger gestellt, um sich zu messen. Und da waren natürlich alle mit ihrer Aufmerksamkeit bei mir. Und dann wurde ich aber aussortiert und durfte nicht mitfahren. Alle waren erst mal schon ein bisschen traurig. Also es kam so ein, vor diesen Hundert Leuten, die da Schlange stand, kam so ein Geräusch. Gross und traurig. Aber sehr viel. Es hat eine eigene Magie, wenn grosse Menschen weinen. Schaden vor der Weine. Das ist was ganz anderes. Wenn ein grosser Mensch, das ist so genauso wie wenn ein starker Mensch weint, das hat was ganz Eigenes. Wenn kleine Menschen lachen. Was haben die zu lachen? Das hat einen ganz eigenen Zauber. Das ist ein ganz besonderer Anblick. Das ist so wie wenn Leute, die so einen riesigen Rucksack haben und dann in der U-Bahn stehen mit so einem riesigen Rucksack. Das ist immer so. Und bitterlich weinen. Und aber auch nur ein T-Shirt anhaben, aber einen riesigen Rucksack. Und richtig, richtig deprimierend bitter, bitter in ihre Hände weinen, wo wirklich die Tränen an den Händen herunterfließen. Nächste Woche ist auch wieder der 11.11. Oh ja. Wo natürlich auch wieder sehr viele kostümierte Menschen zu sehen sind. Aber das wollte ich nicht an mich erinnern, weil du bist ja immer so ein Kandidat, vergisst das, dass es das gibt. Ja, nee, der 11.11., der ja letzte Woche war, ist natürlich immer sehr unangenehm, aber ich bin da immer außer Lande, ich ziehe mich da immer schön zurück in Exil. Ich gehe da schön auf den höchsten Berg, den ich finde, um da zu verharren, in stiller Meditation. Und muss dann danach immer meine Schlüssel wieder wechseln, weil irgendwelche Spasköpfe da die Schlösser kaputt machen. Sei kein Spaskopf. Sei kein Spaskopf und mach es wenigstens lustiger. Schreib da noch einen Gag darüber oder eine Tür oder sowas. Bist du jemand, der meditiert?
Nein, mit meditieren meine ich einfach liegen. Ich glaube, meditieren ist ja ohnehin die Idee, einfach nichts tun zu rechtfertigen, weil jeder meditiert, aber man macht es halt nicht aktiv, sondern du liegst halt einfach da und machst nichts und sitzt auf dem Sofa und guckst dich um und einfach machst nichts. Ich glaube, du tust meditieren Unrecht. Ah, weiß ich. Also ich traue meditierende Leuten nicht und
sage das dir auch ganz offen, ich bin
gegen euch und ich werde
mir rausnehmen, auch Schritte
einzuleiten. Rechtliche Schritte ein sein
oder was? Wenn es sein muss. Wenn es sein muss, rechtlich.
Was sind die Schritte da vor?
Gehe ich schrittlich, naja, also
ich gehe schrittlich vor, erster Schritt
ist eine Abmahnung. Du gehst triff dich
schrittlich vor? Ja. Erster
Schritt ist eine Abmahnung. Erster Schritt ist eine Abmahnung und ich
Vielen Dank. davor? Gehe ich schrittlich, naja, also ich gehe schrittlich vor, erster Schritt ist eine Abmahnung. Du gehst triftig schrittlich vor, erster Schritt ist eine Abmahnung. Erster Schritt ist eine Abmahnung und ich hoffe, dass es nicht dazu kommen muss, aber das liegt auch bei euch. Also könnt ihr euch selber entscheiden, ob ihr so weit gehen wollt oder nicht. Ich bin bereit, sämtliche juristische Register zu ziehen, die nötig sind und von daher, wir sehen uns vor Gericht. Was glaubst du, kann man also für Register ziehen? Ich glaube,
dass, ja, unser Rechtssystem Du lebst so bewusst, du bist so ja bei dir.
Unser Rechtssystem hat da einige,
ein Arsenal an Waffen, die ich
herabfahren lassen kann auf meine
juristischen Gegner und ich bin
gewählt, da auch ordentliche Summen in die Hand
zu nehmen. Ja, es geht jetzt mehr nach Phrasen.
Was verstört dich denn primär?
Also ich würde euch auch zerschmettern mit der ganzen Wucht der Paragraphen. Ja, der ganzen Wucht von Justitia. Als die ganzen Paragraphen lasse ich auf euch herabregnen wie ein Pfeilhagel der Gerechtigkeit. Die ganzen Paragraphen, die meinst du? Ja, die meisten, die meisten. Finde ich, also da bin ich durchaus bereit, auch euch anzugehen. Von daher, versteckt euch, versteckt euch gut. Ich finde es sehr lustig, glaube ich, schon Jerry Seinfeld, der immer gesagt hat, dass Juristen quasi die einzigen sind, wir spielen alle ein Spiel und die Juristen sind die einzigen, die die Gebrauchsanweisungen gelesen haben. Ja, genau. Die gesehen haben, wie man die Spielanleitung gelesen hat. Die wissen, wie es läuft. Ja, die wissen, wie es läuft. Und es gibt ja auch Leute, die spielen UNO jahrzehntelang falsch, bis mal irgendjemand sagt, nee, das geht nicht, man kann die Karte nicht nach der spielen. Und niemand weiss es. Und so ist es, glaube ich, in Jura auch so. Wann darf das nicht? Das sind die einzigen, die mal richtig... Darf das nicht packen? Das sind die einzigen, die Bücher gelesen haben. Ja, die die Gebrauchsanweisungen gelesen haben, die die Packungsbeilagen gelesen haben. Die wissen jetzt Bescheid. Die einzigen, die mal, die mal, eigentlich müssen wir das auch alle machen. Ich verstehe auch gar nicht, warum das ein Beruf ist. Wir sind alle faul und wollen das spielen. Ich habe mir mal so Regelbücher gekauft, BGB, StGB habe ich mir gekauft und auch da mal gerne reingeschmökert. Kann man gerne mal machen. Ist schon echt manchmal ganz spannend zu lesen, wo man aber sich auch manchmal erwischt und sich denkt, oh, da war ich aber auch schon knapp dran, ehrlich gesagt. Da habe ich hier und da schon mal gekratzt am juristisch Machbaren an der Grauzone. Mich stört daran, dass die Seiten so dünn sind. Ja, die sind lächerlich dünn. Ganz dünne Seiten. Du kannst ja teilweise durchgucken. Man kann durchgucken. Ja, die gefällt mir überhaupt nicht. Sind Juristen die einzigen, die fleissig sind und einfach mal so durchballern? Naja, die einfach haben nichts anderes zu tun oder einfach wollen das einfach mal wissen. Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich meine, die meisten haben wahrscheinlich Law and Order gesehen und dachten, oh geil, diese eine Anwältin, die am Ende immer den Fall zuschnürt, bei der alles zusammenläuft, wo man immer denkt, egal was die Detektives machen, am Ende läuft es bei ihr zusammen und sie haut dann den Hammer drauf und beendet das Ding, die will ich sein. Die haben dann alle Ace Attorney auf dem DS gespielt und die dann noch Bock hatten, die wurden dann Juristen.
Das gesehen, dann Suits gesehen und dann natürlich schöne Prise Barbara Salisch obendrauf und dann einfach schön ins Jurastudium und dann einfach mal Paragraphen jonglieren. Ist Barbara Salisch eine richtige Richterin? Eine Richterin? Ich weiß es nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, echte Richterinnen dürfen das nicht. Ich habe jetzt Your Honor gesehen, Brian Cranston Serie miterie mit einem Richter, der korrupt wird und auch da viele juristische Details nicht verstanden, aber ist auch gar nicht nötig, weil dieses geschworene System eh komplett bescheuert ist einfach, aber ist halt perfekt fürs Fernsehen. Also ich glaube, es gibt bestimmt viele amerikanische Juristen, die gesagt haben, Leute, dieses geschworene System funktioniert nicht. Die Leute werden immer von den Mafiosi bedroht, die werden immer umgebracht, die werden entführt, die werden manipuliert. Dieses ganze Gerichtsprozedere ist total unsachlich, weil du einfach auf die niedersten Instinkte anspielen willst, aber der Typ, der das entscheidet, sagt, ja, aber ist schon geil für Filme und Serien, oder? Also es ist halt schon geil irgendwie, es ist halt schon interessant. Und ich mag das auch mal so mal bei einem geschworenen Gericht
zu sein, also dass man in einer Jury
sein muss und dann den Zivildienst
quasi da erbringen muss.
Muss man in Deutschland auch Chefendienst?
Da kannst du ja theoretisch auch zum Gericht berufen werden.
Nee, aber ich gebe zu, ich habe auch schon
seit Monaten meine Post nicht mehr aufgemacht,
ich sammle die mittlerweile noch, ich bin wirklich nicht angekommen,
wo ich die ungeöffnet sammle.
Ich weiß, es ist schlecht, soll man nicht tun,
aber... Nee, ich verstehe schon
gar nicht, wie man auf diese Idee kommt.
Bin, bin ich die ungeöffnet sammle. Ich weiß, es ist schlecht, soll man nicht tun. Aber ich verstehe schon gar nicht, wie man auf diese Idee kommt. Ich bin tatsächlich noch nicht im Gefängnis und ich denke mir, mit jedem Tag, den ich in Freiheit wandle, denke ich mir, scheint schon nicht so schlecht zu sein meine Strategie. Okay. Sich einfach nicht damit rumschlagen. Einfach nicht rumschlagen. Ja, weil dann kriegst du auch so einen Brief, bitte geben sie hier irgendwas an, keine Ahnung, irgend so einen Wert, wenn Sie das bis zum XX nicht tun, dann schätzen wir das. Wo ich sage, oh nein, Hilfe, dann macht ihr das, was ich jetzt machen muss. Oh nein, soll ich es lieber machen. Oh Hilfe, ihr schätzt das. Und dann sage ich, ja dann, oh nein, Hilfe. Oh, dann muss ich es schnell machen, sonst macht ihr das für mich. Nein, eben nicht. Oh nein, das muss ich dringend machen. Oh, hoffentlich vergesse ich das nicht. Schicke ich natürlich nicht ab. Ich finde es lustig, dass ich diese ganzen Sachen verstehe, weil ich die gleichen Briefe bekomme wie du, sie nur lese und weiss, dass du Probleme bekommst, wenn du es nicht machst. Das ist aber auch pädagogisch unklug, wenn du sagst, mach das jetzt bis Mittwoch, ansonsten mache ich es.
Oder einfach sagst, nee, so funktioniert es nicht.
Du musst mir sagen, mach es bis Mittwoch oder du bist am Donnerstag im Gefängnis.
Dann mach ich es. Streng genommen sagen sie es aber auch nicht so.
Sie sagen, wenn du es nicht bis Mittwoch machst, mache ich ihn sehr schlecht für dich.
Ja, okay.
Und so, dass es dein Leben nachhaltig schlechter macht.
Ja, ist mir egal.
Ich habe nämlich da die Gebrauchsanweisung gelesen, mal.
Nee, Hauptsache ich muss nichts machen.
Das ist ein eine schlechte, schlechte Herangehensweise. Deswegen, wie du auch schon gesagt hast, wenn jemand sagt, es eilt nicht, passiert es nicht. Alles muss immer eilen, sonst funktioniert es nicht. Das Leben ist Monopoly und du kommst bald in den Knast. Ja, aber wenn uns Monopoly eins gelehrt hat, dann der Knast ist nicht so schlimm. Nee, du kommst auch nicht lange in den Knast, eine Runde. Nee, weil manchmal kannst du auch von der Position her einen Vorteil haben, wenn du dann im Knast bist, wenn du dann irgendwie über die Felder springst sozusagen. Das Leben ist Monopoly und du bist sehr schlecht. Okay, okay, und du würfelst schlecht und Du hast einen schlechten Würfel. Finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Oder du versuchst da nebendurch Kraftwerke zu kaufen. Das habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden. Warte mal, kenne ich nicht. Nee, gibt es Wasserwerke, glaube ich. Irgend solche Werke gibt es auch, die man kaufen kann. Vier Stück. Kenne ich nicht. Doch, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Aber da bin ich mir auch nicht sicher. Wir hatten irgendwie bei uns als Kinder, bei Monopolizeit, irgendwann alle Scheine verloren und haben angefangen, mit willkürlichen Dingen zu zahlen. Und dann hatten wir irgendwie so Murmeln, die hundert waren. Und dann hatten wir noch irgendwie so kleine Stäbchen, dann hatten wir Äste gefunden, dann hatten wir noch so Lego-Steine. Und irgendwann hatten alle den Überblick verloren. Und das Monopoly-Spiel endete immer nach zehn Minuten mit dem Streit, was ist was wert? Und immer hat die der gesagt, Leute, wir brauchen ein einheitliches System. Das Einzige, was Spaß macht an Monopoly, ist doch dieses Geld, was man dabei hat. Deswegen, das macht so viel Spaß, dass, glaube ich, die Leute sich das auch eingesteckt haben, weil die Kinder so dumm sind, dass sie denken, es hätte echt einen Wert, dieses Geld, und schieben sich das ein. Oder habt ihr so eine kleine Wirtschaft bei euch, so ein Wilschenhaus, du und deine Brüder habt vielleicht dann einfach das als Währung benutzt. Finde ich keine schlechte Idee eigentlich. Und habt ihr so eine Wilsche Währung gehabt, Minivill? Ich finde Idee ohnehin, Geld ist ein gutes System und Kinder müssen an Geld herangeführt werden. Auch als ich Zivildienst gemacht habe, gab es immer irgendwelche Formen von Belohnungspunkten, mit denen die Kinder dann was kaufen konnten. Also finde ich gut, dass man sich sein eigenes Spielgeld verdient, so Krokodildollar, Krokodollar oder irgendwie irgendwas Niedliches oder so. Genau. Und dann machst du einfach, ja, wenn du ein Zimmer aufräumst, kriegst du 15 Krokodollar und wenn du irgendwie WoW spielen willst, dann kostet es 100 Krokodollar pro Stunde, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Ich finde es lustig, weil wir eine Neldung bekommen haben bei Twitter. Da schreibt nämlich der liebe Gago, schreibt, ja, ich bin ein paar Folgen zurück und eventuell wurde es in der späteren Folge schon aufgegriffen, findet das immer noch die beste und immer noch gültige Währung. Und jetzt, durch Zufall haben wir jetzt gerade wieder über Währung gesprochen und was sich durchzieht, und zwar meint er Rai, er hat so einen Wikipedia-Artikel geschickt zu Rai. Dieses Waschmittel, auch Steingeld genannt, ist auf dem Atoll Oliti in Jabb, einem Bundesstaat der föderierten Staaten von Mikronesien. Das klingt alles wie ein Monophiliespiel. Verwendet es Tauschmittel beziehungsweise vormünstliches Zahlungsmittel und gilt immer noch als Zahlungsmittel, obwohl die Herstellung 1931 eingestellt wurde. Es besteht aus Steinscheiben, die überall auf den Inseln am Wegrand oder um die Häuser stehen. Wenn der Eigentümer wechselt, lässt der Erwerber den Stein gewöhnlich aufgrund des Gewichts und der damit entstehenden Schwierigkeiten des Transport dort, wo er ist. Wem welcher Stein gehört, wird einfach im Gedächtnis festgehalten. So, wo ist das was anderes als einfach Geld, was wir haben auf Banken? Nur, dass das Gedächtnis die Bank ist, also ein unbeteilter Dritter im Idealfall. Und weil es geht ja nur darum, dass man grob den Überblick behält, so funktionieren Bitcoins ja auch. Jemand muss verifizieren, dass dir das und das gehört. Moment mal, da liegen Steine auf der Insel rum und die zahlen mit den Steinen, ohne dass sie die Steine bei sich haben.
Richtig.
Sondern du gehst einkaufen und
sagst, ich hätte gerne Leib Brot, dafür gehört dir der
Stein hinten bei Udo, hinten links
da am Vorgarten. Guck dir kurz, ja,
ja, okay. Der Stein gehört es dir. Ja,
machen wir einen Achtelstein,
hast du das Brot. Oh Gott, dann hast du anteilig Steine.
Das ist ein funktionierendes System.
Das ist ein funktionierendes System, aber in
Mikronesien. Und wie der Name schon sagt, ist das, glaube ich, kein grosses, unübersierendes System. Das ist ein funktionierendes System, aber in Mikronesien.
Und wie der Name schon sagt, ist das glaube ich kein großes, unübersichtliches System.
Das ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Ich hoffe, in Mikronesien kommt nie eine Regierung an die Macht, die sagt, wir wollen nicht länger Mikronesien sein, wir werden Makronesien.
Wir nehmen Polen ein, einfach fuck it.
Das klingt einfach wie ein Gag. Das ist auf dem Atoll, auch bereits eine Podcast-Ufo-Folge, Uliti, was ausgedacht klingt wie von uns, in Jabb, weiss ich nicht, warum es noch ein Wort gibt, einem Bundesstaat der federierten Steine von Mikronesien. Ja, und das sind so große Steindinger. Boah, die sind ja riesig. Ja, deswegen, die kann man so nicht transportieren. Die stehen aufrecht. Ich dachte jetzt einfach so Steinscheiben wie Münzen, aber nein, das ist so wie Münzgeld von Riesen. Es sind riesige Steine. Es ist doch völlig gut, du brauchst einfach ja nur, Geld ist ja nur eine begrenzte Anzahl Dinge. Und da ist ein Loch drin. In dem riesigen Stein ist ein Loch drin. Ja, aber wenn ich versuchen würde, es zu fälschen, ich hätte ein Problem mit dem Loch. So eine riesige Steinscheibe kriege ich hin, aber das Loch kriege ich nicht hin. Nee. Wie bohrt man ein Loch in den Steinen? Aber wie genial, weil es ja total, es liegt ja auf der Hand, dass es funktioniert. Es gibt begrenzte Anzahl an Scheiben. Ja. So, und jetzt geht es darum, du musst einfach nur behalten, im Kopf behalten, wie viele du hast. Gut, der naheliegende Streit ist natürlich, jemand behauptet, der Stein gehört ihm und der andere auch, der gehört ihm. Und dann musst du irgendwie
rückverfolgen zu Ute und Udo,
wer hat wem den Stein wann gegeben.
Bring mal nicht deinen wildschen
Bruderzwist nach Uliti
in Jap, weil in Jap
haben die das nämlich raus, Jap und nicht Nope.
Da haben die das nämlich raus, weil
die haben nämlich diesen Streit nicht, da haben die einfach so ein
Inselgedächtnis und alle sagen, ja,
ich weiß, ich kann das bestätigen,
der Udo hat da das Blatt Brot gekauft und hat
dafür die Steinscheibe bekommen. Hast du
Vielen Dank. Weil die haben nämlich diesen Streit nicht, da haben die einfach so ein Inselgedächtnis und alle sagen, ja, ich weiß, ich kann das bestätigen, der Udo hat da das Blatt Brot gekauft und hat dafür die Steinscheibe bekommen. Hast du eine Legende, was Antworten heissen im Schriftverkehr? Also wenn jemand Japp schreibt oder Jopp oder Jipp oder Jepp, sind es für dich unterschiedliche Aussagen oder wenn jemand sagt Ja, Jopp, Jau, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joau, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, Joa, sind das unterschiedliche Antworten für dich? Kannst du daran schon was ablesen, wenn jemand antwortet? Also ich tue mich wirklich schwer mit den Japs und Japs und Japs und Japs und Japs, weil erstmal gibt es Jip nicht so richtig. Also A, E, I, O, U, eigentlich kriegen es alle hin. Japp, Jep, Jopp. Jupp, Jupp, Jupp ist glaube ich das gängig. Ja, Japp ist auch ziemlich beliebt. Die mag ich schon auch alle und ich benutze die auch häufig, aber es kommt ein paar Mal vor, dass wenn ich mir die Nachricht nochmal durchlese, ich dann, wenn ich was ändere, dann eher den Vokal im Japp. Aha. Weil wenn ich sage, oh, das das kommt mir zu flapsig rüber, das ist eher eine Business-Mail, dann würde ich eher aufs Jap gehen. Ich würde auch sagen, Jap ist das seriöseste. Jap ist mit Abschaffung das seriöseste. Dann würde ich sagen, Jap, dann Job und Jupp ist wirklich nur mit engen Vertrauten. Jupp ist halt zu flapsig. Oder kannst du auch in seriösen Business-Mails machen, wenn du dir deiner sehr sicher bist. Ja, ja, ja. Also wenn du diese ganze Situation so unter... Haben sie es wirklich unter Kontrolle, Herr Tietze? Jupp. Jupp. Ja, stimmt. Was mit Jau? Jau mag ich auch. Finde ich super. Jau. Das hat schon so ein bisschen Wow mit drin. Das hat schon so ein bisschen Jau. Wirklich so ein... Ah, ja, machen wir. Aber ich kenne es auch ironisch, Jao. Jao. Jao, genau. Da kann es natürlich alles ironisch sein. Jao, genau. Jao, genau. Jao bringt eine Ironie mit. Definitiv. Joa bin ich gar kein Fan von. Ich kenne es nicht mit H, ich kenne es mit J, O, A. Und Max machte das noch nie. Nee, das ist für mich ein ablehnendes Ja, das ist ein Joa. Ja, aber dann gehe ich all in und sage Nein. Weil wenn du Joa sagst, dann meinst du nicht Joa. Lassen wir das Ganze mal umdrehen. Was ist mit Nob und Nub und Nepp und Nipp? Also kannst du nicht auch Japp, Jopp, Jepp mit N vorne variieren, zu sagen Nob, Nepp. Kommst du mit Nepp? Komischerweise kann man Dinge bejahen, auf unterschiedliche Art und Weise, aber nein ist immer nein.
Ja, nein und nee. Also lass mal nicht nee unter den Teppich fallen.
Ja, aber nee ist ja genau so, definitiv ist nein wie nein.
Nee, das ist schon was anderes, das ist schon...
Nee, guck mal, wie Ablehn der nee gerade war, Ablehn der geht es ja nicht mehr.
Nee.
Ja, eben.
Das ist super nein.
Ja, nein, aber nein ist einfach ganz klares nein. Nee ist auch nein. Nee ist keine Diskussion. Nee, komm. Aber nö ist, oh, nö, nee. So, das ist schon was anderes als nein. Finde ich nämlich nicht. Bei nein kannst du ja nicht strecken. Nein ist nicht so unerschönen. Du kannst nicht sagen, nein. Wenn man so eine Skala hätte. Nein, nee. Er ist schon was anderes. Wenn man so eine Skala hätte zwischen eins, ich lasse mich noch überreden, und zehn, definitives Nein, finde ich sind Nee und Nö eher sieben, acht, neun, da hinten. Nee, nee ist noch ein Nee, ja, okay, aber du sagst nicht Nein, ja gut, nee, nee ist ja fast schlimmer als Nein. Ja, ne ist ganz weit keine Chance. Ne willst du mitkommen? Ne. Aber ich will doch nur, dass du da mit mir mitgehst, weil die Neins, Nines und Nupsis, Nope, sind alle eher sehr, sehr verneinend, also sieben, acht, neun, zehn da hinten, wohingegen die Jups schon eher Joaa, sehr, sehr nah am Richtung Nein geht.
Ja, wir brauchen jetzt eine mehrdimensionale Ausrichtung, dass du sagst Zustimmung, also du hast eine, eine Achse ist Umstimmungswahrscheinlichkeit und eine Achse ist Zustimmung Ablehnung. Nee, das ist das Gleiche. Ne, würde ich nicht sagen. Wenn du sagst, ja und nein ist auf derselben Achse irgendwo, dann musst du schon sagen, ein Nee ist näher am Ja als ein Nein. Wo ist ein Ei? Ei ist ziemlich weit oben. Und nee. Also da musst du schon gucken, aber das ist schon schwierig, da könnt ihr gerne mal die Skala aufmachen. Ihr könnt gerne mal vorbeigucken in unserem Reddit. Reddit das Podcast UFO, wo wir versuchen, die ganzen Community-Einsendungen zu bündeln, wo ihr euch auch alles durchlesen könnt, was sonst so gekommen ist und in die Elfchen-Community einsteigt. Lustigerweise habe ich diese Grafik gefunden, die quasi ähnlich ist, die habe ich schon sehr lange auf meinem Desktop, weil ich nie wusste, wofür ich sie gebraucht habe, fand ich aber toll. Und zwar ist es eine Grafik, die zeigt, how probable is, und dann gibt es verschiedene Wörter, definitely, has a good chance, likely, probably, apparently. Okay, also ganz kurz, definitely ist das Allerwahrscheinlichste. Wenn etwas definitely passiert, dann passiert es zu nahezu hundert Prozent. Wie wahrscheinlich, das kann man so übersetzen, wie wahrscheinlich ist definitiv. Definitiv ist auf jeden Fall nahezu hundert Prozent, das ist sehr wahrscheinlich. Wörter kann man durchaus auch mathematisch benutzen. Ich finde auch Autorendasein, es hat auch viel mit Mathematik und Logik zu tun. Absolut. When pigs fly, das kenne ich nicht, also wenn Schweine fliegen, ist sehr unwahrscheinlich. When hell freezes over, wenn die Hölle zufriert, ist auch nicht so wahrscheinlich. Also das ist das Gegenteil, das ist absolut unwahrscheinlich. When pigs fly.
Sogar noch, when hell freezes over ist sogar noch unwahrscheinlicher als never.
Aber wahrscheinlicher als when pigs fly. Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Schweine fliegen, ist geringer, als dass die Hölle zufriert. Das finde ich schon mal nicht schlecht. Aber sowas gibt's im Deutschen wenig, ne, dieses nee, auf gar keinen Fall, wenn, nee, nee, nee, wenn, mein Schwein pfeift ist was anderes natürlich, das ist erstaunend, aber so. Eher kippt in China ein Sack Reis um, nee, bin ich der Kaiser von China, kennt man doch, ja dann bin ich der Kaiser von China, wenn es morgen regnet, dann bin ich der Kaiser von China. Also, ich bin nicht der Kaiser von Ziele. Habe ich jetzt so noch nicht genau gehört, aber vor allem, ich glaube, auf der anderen Seite ist sowas so sicher wie das Arm in der Kirche. Ja, so sicher wie das Arm in der Kirche. Das ist das deutsche Äquivalent von definitely. So sicher wie das Arm in der Kirche. Das ist 100 Prozent. Aber mir gefällt auch, weil du hast ja nicht nur quasi, es ist ja keine Null- oder Eins-Anzeige, also du hast ja nicht irgendwo einen Strich, sondern du hast ja so eine Welle. Das heißt, und probably zum Beispiel macht einen kleinen Knick in der 50-Prozent-Gegend, um dann wieder leicht runter zu gehen und dann wieder bei 75 Prozent hoch zu gehen. Also probably sagt man auch, wenn man sich so zu 50 Prozent sicher ist, man sagt es häufiger, wenn man sich sehr sicher ist bei 75 Prozent. Mal schauen. Mal schauen ist für mich eher ablehnt. Ich würde sagen, bei mal schauen hat Bimmeria Tendenz zu nein. Wo würdest du sagen, was ist schauen wir mal? Wahrscheinlich oder eventuell? Wahrscheinlich ist schon sehr, ist bei 75%. Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es wahrscheinlicher als eventuell. Aber mal schauen, schauen wir mal. Aber wahrscheinlich finde ich, hätte auch so einen kleinen Ausschlag nochmal bei der 50% gegen. Weil wahrscheinlich sagst du auch, ja, wahrscheinlich. Ja, ich komme wahrscheinlich. Ich komme wahrscheinlich. Das ist schon eher als, ich komme eventuell. Das ist schon, das ist schon wahrscheinlich. Eventuell würde ich fast sagen, 50%. So an der 50% gegen. Ja, schwierig, schwierig. Aber interessant, also wählt eure Antworten weise. Ich glaube auch, also da sind wir eh schon dran, der moderne Knigge, wo einfach genau solche Listen abgedruckt werden müssen, wo man einfach genau weiß, wer wie antwortet, gibt mir auch eine Skala der verschiedenfarmenigen Herz-Emojis. Rot ist das am liebevollsten, wo ist grün, wo ist gelb, wo ist schwarz, wo ist blau. Da glaube ich, brauchen wir den modernen Knigge. Ich schicke immer Rot und kriege immer Grün zurück. Was he das? Wobei Grün heißt ja Go, Grün heißt ja Leglos, also ich gebe dir grünes Licht. Grünes Herz ist grünes Licht. Wobei, dann ist mein Herz aber eher so Schallstopp und weiter geht's nicht. Das ist natürlich jetzt gefährlich, wenn man jetzt die Ampel auch noch mit reinzieht in romantische Angelegenheiten. Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber ich habe das Gefühl, alles ausser Rot ist eher freundschaftlich gemeint. Herrgott, bin ich froh, dass es nicht
noch Farben gibt beim Schreiben. Ja.
Also bei Emojis ist das schon ein Problem.
Jetzt bei den Herzen. Oh, könnte das kommen als
nächster Schritt, nachdem die Emojis jetzt wieder
so ein bisschen Glanz verlieren, zu sagen,
man hat verschiedene Schriftfarben? Naja, gibt's
ja schon ein bisschen. Es gibt Fettgedruck, es gibt Kursiv
und es gibt in Caps. Bei Texten gibt's
kein Fettgedruck. In Texten gibt
es zumindest Caps. Ich benutze
Caps und es gibt die
Die Ja, schon ein bisschen. Es gibt Fettgedruck, es gibt Kursiv und es gibt in Caps. Bei Texten gibt es kein Fettgedruck. In Texten gibt es zumindest Caps. Ich benutze Caps und es gibt die Form noch über Caps, Leerzeichen zwischen Caps. Oh, wow. Was ist mit Punkten zwischen Caps? Abkürzungen. Das sind nur für Abkürzungen. Das ist wie Mesh. Aber da bist du auch drauf. Also selbst wenn du ADAC schreibst, machst du Punkte dazwischen, obwohl es nicht mal offiziell ist, aber du sagst, nein, Abkürzungen, Akronyme werden bei mir mit Punkten abkürzt. X, Y, D, C, ADAC, alles mit Punkten. Ja, muss einfach ein Punkt dabei sein. Ja, finde ich gut. Aber da braucht man, glaube ich, eine Übersicht, dass da einfach nachgeschlagen werden kann. Weil auch für Leute, die Deutsch lernen, ist das ja wahnsinnig schwierig zu verstehen, was das dann alles genau bedeutet, dass man versteht, wenn jemand sagt, mal schauen,
dass das eher Nein heißt. Ich bin eh ein riesiger Grafen-Fan.
Die sind schön anschaulich, so Statistiken in Grafen visualisieren, finde ich immer ganz toll.
Und gerade ein bisschen mehr wieder die Mathematik zurück zur Sprache bringen, ist ja eh schon unser Ansinnen, also lass das mal machen.
Lass das mal machen.
Wo würde man das einordnen?
Ja, können wir mal schauen.
Gucken wir mal.
Ja, du, habe ich jetzt nichts dagegen.
Also, ja, meld dich. Also, ich bin, ich habe, also mal gucken, ob ich Zeit habe.
Nein.
Dann ist Polen offen. Nein. Dann ist Polen offen. Das ist was ganz anderes, da bricht der Damm, das ist der Dammbruch. Oh Gott. Da ist der Damm gebrochen. Da sollte man auch nicht mehr sagen, dann ist Polen offen. Das ist auch komisch, der polnische Abgang und so, warum ist da, kommt das alles aus Oh, das weiß ich nicht genau, was da der Hintergrund ist, aber ich bin großer Fan des polnischen Abgangs, deswegen glaube ich, der wichtigste Teil der polnischen Kultur in meinem Leben ist der polnische Abgang.
In der Schweiz sagt man, einen französischen machen.
Ja, und tatsächlich in Frankreich heißt der Leberkäse Fromage d'Italie.
Also in Frankreich heißt der Leberkäse italienischer Käse, obwohl der gar nicht aus Italien kommt.
Aber man eignet sich auch auf Käse.
Man eignet sich auch auf Käse, das auf jeden Fall.
Beide eignen sich auf das Falsche.
Im Grunde schon, ja, wo man auch sagen könnte, Kuchen.
Ist das auch ein Fleischkuchen?
Ist denn in Leberkäse Leber drin? Nein, auch nicht.
Boah, keiner, ich glaube, da ist alles drin, das willst du nicht wissen. Weder Käse noch Leber.
Da ist einfach alles reingemischt.
Das ist ja wirklich wie so eine schaumfluffige Schaumteigmischung, wenn du das mal roh siehst.
Das ist echt abgefahren, was das ist.
Da gibt es eine ganz, ganz tolle Doku vom Bayerischen Rundfunk.
Ich bin ein sehr guter Typ. alles reingemischt. Das ist ja wirklich wie so eine schaumfluffige Schaumteig-Mischung, wenn du das mal roh siehst. Das ist echt abgefahren, was das ist. Da gibt es eine ganz, ganz tolle Doku vom Bayerischen Rundfunk. Ich schaue ja gerne manchmal so diese Heimat-Dokus vom Bayerischen Rundfunk, wo dann Leute so halt wird Leberkask macht. So, und dann gehst du so in eine Metzgerei und dann, ja, wir machst das, ja, zeig mal so, und dann schmeißen die da alles mögliche rein und so, und das ist schon cool. Ja, immer diesen cholerischen Fabrikbesitzer. Aber vermisst du manchmal auch deine Heimat Bayern? Ich freue mich immer, wenn ich da hingehe, auf jeden Fall jetzt auch zu Weihnachten natürlich wieder schön zu Hause und dann Skiforren, Skiforren und schön ein bisschen powdern, du hast so richtig schön im Neischnee. So, da gehst du dann rein, das ist dann schon schön, aber ist es nicht so, dass ich Sehnsucht hätte irgendwie,
sondern wenn ich dann da bin, dann genieße ich es auch und dann freue ich mich auch. Ganz kurze
Frage, ich pendel ja
zwischen Köln und Hamburg
und jetzt nähert sich natürlich wieder
die schönste Zeit des Jahres, Weihnachtszeit.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen
zum Thema Adventskalender.
Ist es erlaubt,
wenn man zwei Wohnsitze hat, ist es erlaubt, zwei Adventskalender zu haben? Weil die Alternative wäre ja, ich bin ein paar Tage in Hamburg, kehre zurück nach Köln und mache gleichzeitig vier, fünf Türchen auf. In meiner Rechnung ist das die grössere Sünde, an einem Tag mehrere Türchen aufzumachen, als zwei Adventskalender zu haben. Ich habe seit Jahren mehrere Adventskalender. Man kann das ja auch gar nicht verhindern. Da braucht man sich gar nicht so groß angucken mit so großen Augen. Man kriegt von ein paar Leuten Adventskalender geschenkt. Oder vielleicht manchmal, lustigerweise immer von so einer Firma, wo man so Musik gekauft hat, früher für das Neomagazin zum Beispiel. Da bin ich mit so einer Kartei angemeldet für so Musiklizenzen, die man kaufen kann, wo den kriege ich immer einen Adventskalender. Aber ich finde das dreist. Meine Mutter schickt mir einen Adventskalender. Ich finde das dreist, jemanden einen Adventskalender zu schicken, weil ich finde, jeder Mensch sollte einen Adventskalender haben und das finde ich dreist, wenn du jemanden einen Adventskalender schickst, zu sagen, hier, ich bin der einzige, der entscheidet, welchen Adventskalender du hast. Weil ich finde das skandalös, was du hier gerade so lapidar nebenbei sagst, dass bei dir selbstverständlich mehrere Adventskalender zu Hause rumstehen. Ich finde das ein Skandal. Ich bin echauffiert. Du kamst gerade von dem Punkt, dass du gesagt hast, du willst die Zweikaufnahme. Ja, aber deswegen habe ich da so Gewissenskonflikte, dass ich sage, eigentlich geht das ja nicht. Ich finde, das geht. Ich finde sogar auch mehrere Tücher in einem Tag aufzumachen, völlig legitim. Also in welchen Sündenpfuhl bin ich denn hier eigentlich reingeraten gerade? Knietief bin ich hier in der moralischen Verkommenheit. Das ist wie ein heidnisches Haus. Bei mir gelten diese Regeln eigentlich. Gottlose Leute wieseln da wirklich im Sündenpfuhl rum. Das ist ja hier Sodom und Gomorra. Ja, in meinem Eis.de Adventskal was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, wird. Ja, genau. Weil man stellt sich immer so vor, dass so liebevoll hinter die Türchen gelegt ist. Und dann so eine Elfe macht dann so die Türchen, das Türchen noch zu. Genau, zerschnürt das dann so und verschließt das Türchen. Aber das ist wirklich die grösste Entzauberung, ist es da mal reinzugucken. Ich habe ja lange Zeit den After-Adventskalender, Big Ben-Kalender gehabt, bis ich den eines Jahr mal einfach in enormer Geniestreich-Manier auf die Heizung gestellt habe und dann irgendwie die Heizung an war und dann halt einfach die ganze Minzschokolade durch den gesamten Turm durchgeflossen ist, durch die Rinnen durch und sich unten gesammelt hat und dann so rausgetropft ist. Und das war so ekelhaft, dass ich seitdem, glaube ich, kein After-Eten mehr essen konnte, weil das alles hat sich so vermischt und das ist ja auch teilweise so weiße Schokolade und dann matscht sich das alles und es tropft dann so auf den Boden und irgendwann machst du dann ein Türchen auf und da ist nichts drin und denkst, was ist denn jetzt los und dann merkst du, dass die alle abgehauen sind und alle sich unten geschmolzen und versammelt haben und seitdem kann ich das nicht mehr sehen. Du warst kurz davor, Afterhead anzurufen und zu sagen, oh, was ist da los? Ja, ich war wirklich kurz davor an der, ja, merke ich es ja noch Hotline eingerichtet für echauffierte Leute, die eine Nullnummer haben im Adventskalender natürlich hin, was ja ein Skandal ist, aber da war ich selber schuld und seitdem habe ich immer ein Vertrauen. Aber du sagst, es freut mich ja, dass du sagst, zwei Adventskalender gehen in Ordnung. Es ist doch, wir müssen uns, glaube ich, alle mal so ein bisschen entspannen, was diese ganze Adventskalender-Diskussion angeht. Nee, ich wir müssen uns mehr spannen. Wir haben uns zu lange entspannt, wir haben uns zu lange gechillt, Max, relax. Ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt mal wieder eine gesunde Anspannung in uns bringen und sagen, nein, es gibt Prinzipien, hinter denen stehen wir. Ich finde, das ist total okay, finde ich auch. Ich finde aber gut, beim Adventskalender zu sagen, nee, das ist mal eine Freizeit, da gönne ich mir mal jetzt so ein bisschen was. Man geht ja auch Richtung Weihnachten los. Also ich finde da ja auch gut, Weihnachten ist ja so eine Schlemmzeit, so eine Genieserzeit. Draussen hat dir das Wetter nicht mehr zu bieten, so. Das ist völlig okay, da mal ein bisschen über die Stränge zu schlagen und so mal ein paar Töcher mehr aufzumachen. Kein Problem. Vor allem, da lernst du ja auch schnell, ah, du hast nichts davon. Wenn du im Vorhinein genascht hast, hast du halt ein paar Tage nichts.
Der Adventsgeländer, der zeigt dir ja,
wie du lebst, der hält dir einen Spiegel vor.
Und so einen zweiten Adventsgeländer
finde ich okay.
Es gibt tatsächlich auch Adventsgeländer von Spiegelherstellern,
wo jedes Türchen, das du aufmachst,
einfach einen Spiegel und du selber bist das Geschenk.
Das ist eigentlich eine schöne Geste.
Du hast halt 24 Minispiegel,
die einfach messerscharf sind, die du dann im Haus verteilen kannst. So als Minispiegel, die du überall hinhängen kannst. Ja, meine Mutter und diese Freundinnen und Verwandte machen jetzt so eine, kennt man ja, manche Freundeskreise machen das, die stellen sich so Weihnachts-Adventskalender zusammen. Und ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden und sie auch nicht. Das Problem ist, es machen 24 Leute mit. Und es macht es halt, die Regeln zu erklären, sehr kompliziert, weil es ausgerechnet 24 Tage sind. Und alle waren verwirrt. Die einen haben 24 Mal ihr Geschenk gekauft, also irgendwie haben sie geeinigt, drei Euro das maximal kosten, und jeder hat ein Tor zugewiesen bekommen. Und jetzt mussten die aber 24, jetzt schwirrte diese Zahl 24 rum und alle waren verwirrt und eigentlich haben alle primär angefangen, 24 verschiedene drei Euro Geschenke zu kaufen, was nicht nur sehr teuer wurde, sondern auch grosser Aufwand, weil 24 unf unfassbar Aufwand, grosser Aufwand, 24 Sachen zu finden. So, und jetzt kam dann raus, nee, ihr müsst 24 mal das gleiche kaufen für drei Euro. Und es sind in jedem Türchen 24 Geschenke, oder was? Genau, das war dann der erste Knoten im Gehirn. 24 hoch 24. So, und jetzt wurde es genauso teuer wie dieses teure Rechenexempel ganz am Anfang, aber jeder hat nur 24 Mal seinen 3-Euro-Gegenstand gekauft. So, und jetzt werden daraus von den 24 Leuten, die mit teilnehmen, werden jetzt 24 Adventskalender die gleichen, also baugleiche Adventskalender. Quasi jeder Teilnehmer hat eine Tür zugewiesen bekommen. Ja, okay. Genau. Und jetzt kommt quasi das gleiche Geschenk 24 Mal ins Tor sieben zum Beispiel. Und am Ende entstehen jetzt für die 24 teilnehmenden Menschen 24 Adventskalender mit 24 verschiedenen Dingen drin. Aber wirklich, dieser Aufwand, 24 verschiedene Sachen zu finden, ist enorm. Ich habe ja nur mal nebenbei mitbekommen, dass irgendeine, ich glaube, bei uns in der Maske war das, die so nebenbei erzählt hat, so ja, mein Freund hat mir jetzt einen Adventskalender geschickt, total süss aufmerksam, wo man natürlich anfängt zu denken, so fuck, ich wäre im Leben nie auf die Idee gekommen, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung zu machen. Und dann habe ich mir auch überlegt, okay, fuck, jetzt wie viele Türchen kriegst du hin, so man, wie viele, man hat ja irgendwelche Insider-Gemeinsamkeiten, so und dann fallen einem halt so sieben Sachen ein. Und dann denkst du, soll ich dir jetzt einfach mal drei und dann Rest drei im Sinn, vier minus Quadrat Hypotenuse oder lass ich. Vor allem wie lustig, wenn so die ersten sieben Dinge, die ersten sieben Türchen sind einfach mega überlegt, süße Insider zwischen dem Pärchen und so. Und dann ab Tor acht einfach so ein Stückchen Schokolade. Und dann aber alle bis 24 einfach so ein Schokobon. Jeden Tag. Ja, so ein Schokobon. Und im letzten steht so, ja, vielleicht sollten wir es lassen. So ein kleiner Zettelchen. Das ist die süsseste Art, Schluss zu machen. Ist einfach, wo sie selber auch keinen Bock mehr hat, weil sie denkt, es hat so gut angefangen, jetzt ist nur noch Schokobonaus. Sie wird an die Trennung herangeführt. Ja, genau. Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. Sie fängt Tüch an. Sie werden immer schlechter jeden Tag und am Ende nur noch so ein Gummibärchen. Du weißt auch, sie mag kein After-Aid, Tor 23, After-Aid. Oh ja, finde ich gut. Und dann Tor 24, ja, vielleicht sollten wir es lassen. Ja, finde ich wirklich eine gute Idee. So ein Bild mit dir und einer anderen. Also, falls ihr in der Beziehung gefangen seid und wollt raus, nutzt einfach mal die Adventszeit aus, um vielleicht jetzt da einen Schlussstrich unterzuziehen und fangt neu an, fangt neues neue Jahr neu an. Ich finde, das ist eine sehr süße eigentlich Idee. Wenn ihr da euren Liebsten was machen sollt, das ist der neue Standard. Das ist der neue Standard für eine gute Beziehung. Das ist das Gemeinste, was man machen kann, ist dann, Leute ein schlechtes Gewissen zu machen, die einfallslos sind und die einfach keinen Bock haben auf sowas und dann zu suggerieren, das sei normal. Auf gar keinen Fall. Das ist neu und normal. Nein, das ist... Jeder, der das nicht macht und nicht auf mindestens 30 Ideen, die noch mit Mühe und Not runtergekürzt werden müssen, auf es sind ja nur 24 Türchen da, wenn ich mindestens das hinkriege, der ist ein schlechter Beziehungsgegenstand. Das ist gemeint. Du machst den Leuten schlechtes Gewissen. Ne, wir haben auch eine gewisse Verantwortung. Stefan Tietze, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, du hast mir in dieser Folge nicht gefallen. Ich muss jetzt einmal sagen, erstmal kommt, also dein Adventskalender. Nein, erstmal zu sagen, Grenzüberschreitung im Freizeitpark. Das war letzte Folge. Und jetzt kommst du hier noch mit, von wegen schlechtes Gewissen den Leuten hier irgendwelche Vorgaben zu machen. Ja. Also von mir kriegst du eine Abmahnung. Ich bin bereit, dich juristisch zu verfolgen, kriegst du eine Abmahnung. Ich finde hier Florentin Lamo McVill finde ich auch nervig, dass du da so einen komischen Bezug zu Adventskalender hast. Ich weiß nicht, was da für ein Kindheitstrauma mitschwingt. Ich halte mich halt an die Regeln. Ich kaufe gleich in Rewe und kaufe mir zehn Adventskalender und esse die noch heute. Nein, das wachst du nicht. Haben wir schon Dezember? Stefan, das wachst du nicht. Nein! Das wachst du nicht. Am 8. Oktober mache ich schon die Zehn leer. Stefan, das wachst du nicht. Das ist die letzte Podcast-UFO-Folge aller Zeiten. Wir hören hier an der Stelle auf. Ich kann nicht weiter mit dir zusammenarbeiten, ich kann nie wieder unter deine Augen treten. Das wird nichts. Macht das nicht. Ansonsten, wir wünschen euch eine fantastische Zeit, eine Vorweihnachtszeit. Haut rein, schaut mal gerne auf Patreon vorbei, patreon.com slash das Podcast UFO, ob der UFO-Club was für euch ist, werbefreie Folgen, einen Tag früher und Rabatt im Merch-Shop, wo ihr jetzt auch vielleicht schon die ersten Weihnachtsgeschenke kaufen könnt, falls ihr Freunde oder Verwandte habt, die Podcast UFO-Fans sind, schaut hier gerne mal rein und ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche, macht's gut.
Macht's gut, wir heben auch, macht's gut, ciao.
It's the worst world production.